[Music]
at the top of any US dollar bill you'll
see this
that's because even though the bill may
have come from the treasury the Federal
Reserve is who actually distributes it
they're the ones that's charged with
managing the currency in circulation in
our economy in other words they can kind
of print money money printer go Burr
right that was a popular meme in 2020
when the Fed was creating money out of
thin air the Federal Reserve is in many
ways in charge of the U.S economy as a
former chairman once said they're the
economy chaperone who has ordered the
punch bowl removed just when the party
was really warming up
which means they know their decisions
like raising interest rates aren't
always popular the FED is just this
poorly understood and really important
institution in our country it's
important for people to know what's
going on in the economy they should
understand why we have the FED why it
does what it does and what role it plays
in the country
so let's explain how did the FED get put
in charge of the punch
the FED as we know it has evolved over
time after responses to financial crises
gave it more and more responsibility so
let's start with why the Fed was created
in the first place in the early 1900s
Bank runs were pretty common if a bank a
private business went out of business
that meant everyone lost their deposits
fearful people would run to their
healthy Bank to withdraw their money
only banks didn't keep that much cash
handy so they'd fail causing more people
to fearfully run to their bank and back
then there was nowhere for these Banks
to get more cash to stop these runs
after a large run in 1907 wealthy
Bankers like JP Morgan put up their own
money to essentially bail them out after
that panic in 1907 business and
political leaders got together and said
maybe this isn't the best way to run a
modern economy to rely on a few wealthy
individuals doing the right thing in a
time of Crisis and so discussions began
about creating a central bank or what
became the Federal Reserve System in
1913 the Federal Reserve was created to
be the United States Central banking
system basically a bank for banks its 12
separate federal reserve banks set up
all across the country you had a lot of
distrust still in the country over
having One Bank the idea was that it
might be too powerful so you could go to
different parts of the country and say
well the power won't be in New York it
won't be in Washington it'll be here
there'll be a bank in Atlanta there'll
be a bank in Kansas City it'll be a bank
in San Francisco in Minneapolis and two
in Missouri there was a senator from
Missouri who was instrumental in
creating the Federal Reserve System and
lo and behold there's a Fed Bank in St
Louis and in Kansas City the idea was
they would each represent different
regions of the country and would
independently set their own policies and
interest rates on the money Banks would
keep with them there was also a
president put in charge of each Bank
then the Great Depression hid it widely
agreed by historians that the federal
reserve banks in action and them keeping
the circulation of money and lending too
tight made the depression worse and by
widely agreed nearly a century later a
Fed Governor said we did it there were
concerns even before the Great
Depression that the political compromise
that had been necessary to create this
thing had created too much decentralized
power nobody really was in charge so in
1935 Congress put the washington-based
Board of Governors in charge it would be
a group of seven people from different
parts of the country including a
chairman each nominated by the president
and confirmed by the Senate just like a
Supreme Court Justice they oversee the
Federal Reserve System these Banks they
also serve on the Federal Open Market
Committee the fomc which also includes
Five bank presidents one from New York
and four that rotate this is the group
of people who get together and decide
things like interest rates when you talk
about a Fed meeting you're talking about
a meeting of the fomc the terms become
interchangeable because there are
certain things that the fomc does there
are certain things that the FED board
does and they all kind of blend together
so that's how we got to the basic
foundation of the FED but the FED as we
know it today with its many
responsibilities was built from
responses to even more financial crises
let's start with inflation in the 70s
and in 1978 when Congress gave the fed
or really the fomc two main priorities
the Fed was given a dual mandate to
focus on stable prices and maximum
employment now sometimes those goals
conflict with each other when you're
trying to crush inflation sometimes
you're going to do things that cause
unemployment to go up but the Mandate
really said the FED should take both of
these objectives into account when they
set policy this was because in the 70s
inflation was really high called the
great inflation now a mix of bad luck
and bad policies saw inflation reach
nearly 15 percent there were concerns
that the FED succumbed to political
pressure in the early 1970s because the
FED share at the time Arthur Burns was
friendly with the president and Nixon
did not want him to raise interest rates
before his re-election in 1972. so the
whole experience of the great inflation
reinforced this idea that we should have
politically independent Central Banking
that General generally when you kept
politics out of the fomc boardroom you
had better economic outcomes in 1979
President Jimmy Carter put Paul volcker
in charge of the fed and he raised
interest rates a lot like to nearly 20
percent unemployment skyrocketed and
Rose above 10 percent and people blamed
the Fed
home builders would mail two by fours to
the fed and say stop these oppressive
interest rates they would mail keys for
cars and houses to the FED saying these
are homes and cars that aren't being
sold there were tractors that protested
driving around at the fed's headquarters
history has Vindicated the moves of the
volcker fed he's lionized today as this
figure who did something that was really
hard and really unpopular but if you
look at the U.S economy over the 30
years that followed the U.S economy
performed better than most other
advanced economies the FED gained
credibility because it was politically
independent since politics don't always
make great economic policies and when
the 2008 financial crisis arrived the
FED chairman Ben Bernanke learned from
lessons of the past the Bold measures
the FED took in response to the recent
financial crisis reflected in part its
determination to avoid repeating the
same sorts of mistakes it made before
and during the Great Depression of the
1930s those bold measures included
things the FED had never done before
like dropping interest rates to near
zero for the first time in addition to
managing the currency in circulation and
the occasional treasury security it
started loaning money a lot of money to
non-banks it also got into New Markets
buying things like mortgage Securities
all this to pump money into the economy
this got the FED even more involved in
parts of the financial system Beyond
just currency and interest rates one of
the things Bernanke was well regarded
for was that he just threw everything
against the wall to see what would stick
he made sure that it didn't get worse we
call it the Great Recession and not the
Second Great Depression and Congress
also gave it more authority of oversight
and regulation of the banking system
through Dodd-Frank and just kind of by
default of inaction government spending
retreated after the stimulus in 2009 and
so there was this saying that the FED
had become the only game in town if you
needed to stimulate your economy you
weren't going to be able to cut taxes or
spend more money because Congress didn't
want to do that what ended up happening
was that financial markets to a greater
and greater degree began to hang on
every word and every utterance of the
Fed chair because now monetary policy
was just so important to the markets and
also to the economic outlook for the
country then came covid the FED took
from the Great Recession Playbook it
bought those same assets it began
loaning more money to even more
non-banks and it raised the amount of
money in circulation
spur what you see is a central bank that
during periods of severe stress really
you know National Emergency is willing
to do quite a lot to make sure that the
economy and the financial system holds
together including when inflation Rises
today in support of these goals the fomc
raised its policy interest rate by
one-quarter percentage point the Federal
Reserve began as a response to a
financial crisis and has only grown with
each one since although not always
without criticism the time has come
that's in the fed the FED is primarily
still a bank for banks but it has also
become the stop gap for most other parts
of the financial system they can make
decisions quickly and without political
Fallout to the extent you have a handful
of unelected people making huge
decisions about the economy it's
something that Congress and the White
House our elected leaders have really
decided over many decades to really
Outsource this to the FED basically it's
easier for the parents to rely on The
Chaperone
foreign